Google Cloud recently announced
generative AI app builder or gen app
builder for sure gen app builder lets
developers even with limited ml skills
easily tap into the power of Google's
Foundation models search expertise and
conversational AI Technologies to create
generative AI apps it offers an
orchestration layer that abstracts the
complexity of combining Enterprise
systems with Gen AI tools to create a
smooth user experience now you can build
in minutes or hours with direct API
access to Foundation models out of the
box templates and pre-built connectors
build apps that infer the intent of a
user's question and serve responses with
the required citations and attributions
ensuring data isolation and sovereignty
search and respond with more than just
text customers can type talk tap and
submit images and gen apps can reply
with text voice and media combine
natural conversations with structured
flows blend the output of foundation
models with step-by-step conversation
orchestration to guide customers to the
right answers gen apps can also connect
to purchasing and provisioning systems
and escalate customer conversations to a
human agent when the context demands